according to research by economist
America has more low-paying jobs than
any other developed country in the world
that's the new statistic yeah now out of
34 nations surveyed including Italy
Japan and Greece none had a higher
percentage of low-paying jobs than our
country do you realize what this means
ladies and gentlemen USA is number one
[Applause]
some Americas low-paid heroes there's
many a Quiznos sandwich maker who's $8
an hour there's Barbara a public
schoolteacher had to take a second job
selling bootleg fireworks
there's Tami a Holiday Inn Express
prostitute who rakes in 38 99 tonight
plus free shower gel and conditioner
Ethan is a Huffington Post blogger who
earns about 650 every time he poses
celebrity nip-slip Oliver is a homeland
security agent trying to get a better
paying job at Quiznos and Andy is a talk
show
[Applause]
fabulous
[Music]
[Applause]
you